die leute werden schon wieder
leichtsinnig das sieht man in den parks
und da den umfragewerten von markus
söder deshalb ein mann greift durch
also ich zusammen mit dem ordnungsamt
neues okay ich noch mal los das war es
losgeht siehst du erstmal die western
die ausbildung der sicher ausbildung
musst du dich erst mal verdienen ohne
westrum zu laufen wollte die eigentlich
zum polizei und dann ist was
schiefgelaufen
es ist ernst jetzt nein nicht ziehen die
frage zurück
[Musik]
bitte abstand halten alle bitte abstand
halten wenn sie nicht über die linie
übertreten ist ganz wichtig geht hier
noch weiter also immer aufpassen
ich habe sie im blick gehören sie
zusammen über können sie das ja noch
beweisen
ja
sie haben personal ja natürlich
ja du hast ich habe hier mein zuhause
aber sie haben zu hause
darin ist schlecht wir müssen das jetzt
hier verfolgen in unserer stadt
natürlich oder prüfen sie auch in andere
städte neuss ist ein sündenpfuhl wissen
sie bitte das eis nur mit mundschutz
verzehren erlebt man auch dass die leute
anrufen und leute verpetzen ja ist
eigentliche tagesgeschäft gehört dazu ja
dann kriegen wir alt aus der zentrale
mal in angriff
klose zentrale mal ein anruf ja guck mal
da und danach da ist glaube ich party
hat jemand angerufen der nachbar oder
sonst was meistens bleiben die anonym
ja also manchmal schluss dass die
deutschen spaß daran haben ihren
nachbarn zu verpfeifen wir deutsche sind
deutsche es wäre ganz wichtig dass sie
alle abstand halten
das ist keine übung sonst hole ich den
wasserwerfer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fabian war ja ja verbot gilt auch für
dich heißt ja gut also mit ihnen auch
niemand zu nahe kommt aber wir fast
eigentlich auch selber auch ja aber ich
eine zehner kommen ich möchte ihnen da
einfach nur helfen ja bitte die
abstandsregeln einheiten
[Applaus]
doppelt hält besser aber sie fühlen sich
jetzt durchaus auch sicherer durch
konnte ich ihnen schon helfen ja sehr
gerne
unser ziel ist jetzt nicht die leute
auseinander zu nehmen da ist nur zu
sensibilisieren gut meistens tut zeit
während die meistens hören die er auch
erst wenn die lassen müssen ja ja aber
also wenn s aktien vom ordnungsamt geben
würde dann sollte man die stromsteuer
kaufen drei leute wenn ihr einfach
stehen bleiben
ich würde mir natürlich irgendwie links
dann vorbei da würde ich sie bitten dann
sofort das ordnungsamt anzurufen
ihr handy war und ist ein handy mit dem
nächsten mal handy mitnehmen und dann
was machen wir dann alles erbrochen
immer wenn sie was sehen ich wollte nur
sagen sie sind allein unterwegs ist
wenig vorbildlich weiter paar weiter so
sie hätten in düsseldorf denke ich auf
den rheinterrassen sieht anders aus
düsseldorf ist schlimm dass man froh
dass man hier ein neues darüber hier ist
das ordnungsamt neues auch wenn
düsseldorf geht abstand halten konnte
dann auch was von mir lernen von stück
gebe ich weiter die frage das ist eine
schwere frage ich euch sagen also ich
kann schon verstehen dass du die frage
weiter gegeben hast du bist halt noch
jung und forsch wir können ja sagen ich
habe ein stück sicherer gemacht wenn du
heute wieder nach hause fährst ja was
ich heute ein neues gelernt habe kann
ich jetzt mein leben lang anwenden
jeder vorne abstand einhalten
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]